so there's a couple of things from this
past weekend that I wanted to talk about
and if it's not too late by now
hopefully it's not NPR published an
article about the Pope and about this
story last week - the Pope allegedly
denied the existence of Hell which you
know we'll talk about that some other
time that's a story in and of itself but
you know it's a big story I mean it's a
it's a it's a big story in the world of
Christianity and religion so you would
think NPR being this respectable news
organ donor Specht them but some people
respect them apparently so being this
respectable news organization you would
think they would you know go and find a
reporter who knows like something about
Christianity really you think they'd go
and find their expert Christianity
reporter their their religion expert and
maybe they did maybe they went and they
found the person at NPR who knows
absolutely the most about Christianity
and that person wrote this article about
the Pope and the last and remember this
article would have had to been it was
written by someone and then and then it
would have had to pass through a few
levels of there'd be an editor and then
I mean they're probably a couple levels
before it even gets to the website so
gets through all these levels and the
articles fine until you get to the end
the last sentence this is what the last
sentence says okay the last sentence is
Easter the day celebrating the idea that
Jesus did not die and go to hell or
purgatory or anywhere at all but rather
arose into heaven is on Sunday what what
let's just try to
practice here for a minute and we'll
start with the fact that that's just a
horribly written sentence that that
sentence in and of itself is an
abomination it is a disgrace to
sentences because it's you could have
just said Easter's on Sunday and most
people that's enough you really didn't
have to even say that because everybody
knows what Easter is so you probably
didn't even need that include that line
but then if you're going to write in the
middle of Easter and is on Sunday you're
going to include this whole definition
of Easter you maybe want to make sure
that it's the right definition maybe
check Wikipedia or even the Bible is a
book that came out recently and I heard
is a pretty good a pretty good reference
for these things but more to the point
but first of all most Christians do
believe that Jesus Christ descended into
hell it's right there in the Creed
second Jesus did not ride I know you
know this but I you know in case there
are any NPR reporters watching Jesus
Christ did not rise into heaven he did
not ascend into heaven on Easter he
ascended into heaven forty days after
Easter and in the meanwhile he was here
on earth this is basic Christianity I
mean basic basic and the the reporter of
NPR allegedly a respected news outlet
the reporter tasked with covering a big
religious story did not know why
Christians celebrate Easter I mean good
lord
yeah and then next so that's that was
one thing and then I think was on the
same day you had yet Chuck Todd another
respected journalist and he tweeted on
Good Friday this was his tweet he said
I'm a bit hokey when it comes to Good
Friday I don't mean disrespect to the
religious aspect of the day but I love
the idea of reminding folks that any day
can become good all it takes is a little
selflessness on our part works every
time
see hokey is not the word I would use
I would there are many words that I
could use to describe that tweet
I wouldn't use most of those words
because I'm a Christian and because I'm
a Christian I know that we call it Good
Friday because Jesus died a horrific
horrible gruesome death that day and
that's only good because he redeemed
mankind through his death and
resurrection but not because it was
actually good in the sense that you mean
it Chuck I I just imagined Chuck Todd
falling into a worm hole or something
and then ending up 2,000 years ago and
strolling up to Calvary and just looking
around and you know like say why all the
glum faces folks I mean just remember
just just have a positive attitude and
everything will be fine
of course I say that I know you know I
say well I know what Good Friday is
because I'm a Christian but really you
shouldn't need to be a Christian at all
to know what Good Friday is or to know
what Easter is because this is basic
cultural literacy that these people who
work for these elite media outlets do
not possess Christianity I don't care
how you feel about Christianity it's one
of the biggest it is I'm sorry it is the
biggest religion in the world the
biggest religion in the history of the
world the the the biggest in America by
a long shot
and it's been the number one driving
force in our civilization for centuries
though it is less so now than it used to
be admittedly all in all as an educated
person if you want to be an educated
person if you want to be an intelligent
person you have to understand how the
world works you have to possess a basic
knowledge and understanding of
Christianity whether you believe in it
or not I mean every you know if you want
to understand anything about art over
the last two thousand years
literature government philosophy yes
even science okay if you want to really
understand the genesis and the history
and the meaning and the substance behind
all of those things you got to know
something
Christianity because Christianity has
been the driving force and the substance
of all of those things for centuries and
you know this is why in case anyone was
wondering this is why they used to teach
the Bible in public school they did that
doesn't mean that you were required to
believe in the Bible in public school
but for a long time in public school in
secular school you were taught the Bible
you read the Bible in public school and
that makes a lot of sense because the
Bible I mean it's only the most
influential piece of literature ever
written hands town and nothing else even
comes close to it so if you're gonna
study influential literature in school
it kind of doesn't make sense to skip
over the number one I mean that is a
huge mountain to just to just jump over
and pretend it's not even there it's
like if you were studying mountains and
you never even acknowledged Everest
that's what it's like it's like if if
there were kids entire time in school
and they study different you know
geological formations they study
mountains but they never it just Everest
we're gonna pretend Everest doesn't
exist the Bible is the Mount Everest of
of literature of books and that's not my
subjective determination that's not just
I'm saying it because I believe in it
that's just what it is historically
speaking but our PC society has decided
that it's too it's too triggering it's
it's too upsetting for the little
Atheist children to be exposed to this
book that shaped the world so they
ignore it and they read The Hunger Games
or a Harry Potter instead that's what
they read instead of acknowledging the
Bible and that guy there's a there's a
quote it's either from Chesterton or
Lewis I can't remember which one where I
think it was Chesterton who said that an
atheist can never be too careful in his
in his reading whereas if you're a
Christian you can read whatever you want
but as an atheist you have to try really
hard to protect that that vulnerable
worldview that you've created it's a
very fragile thing and so you have to be
very careful not to read things like the
Bible
because if you do that everything may
start falling apart and I think that
that you know that's basically how our
society operates and what do you end up
with when we all kind of just ignore you
know when people who aren't Christian
make no effort to understand what
Christianity is what we end up with is a
society with a lot of people who hate
Christianity but do not understand
Christianity they don't know what it is
they don't know what it means they don't
know what it teaches but they despise it
and they look down on anyone who
believes in it even though they don't
understand it and and I don't need Chuck
Todd or NPR to prove that point you know
we see this any Christian okay let's
just take two examples that any
Christian who you know has gotten into
debates especially online has
encountered these two things which I
think kind of encapsulate this issue of
the people who hate Christianity the
most are the ones who know the least
about it so two so two pieces of
evidence that I'll submit to prove my
point first you have the secular person
the kind of sneers and scoffs and he
says he says oh so you believe you
believe that there's an invisible
invisible magical sky genie up in the
clouds that's what you believe yeah you
believe in the invisible sky man huh and
then they look at each other and they
give each other high-fives is it oh did
you hear what I just said about the
invisible sky man yeah that was a clever
one yeah you never heard that one before
did you really got him on that one no I
I don't believe in the invisible sky man
nobody believes that okay that's like if
I told you about the Sun and and you
said oh so you believe there's a giant
candle floating in the sky you hear this
guy he thinks there's like a giant
Yankee candle just just hovering in the
sky no that's not what I said it's not
what I said at all that's what you're
saying
that's your understanding of this you're
showing your own ignorance you should be
embarrassed no there isn't any adult
Christian who believes
God is literally in the clouds okay
you see that's just an illustration that
people use that artists have used that
poets that you have used that writers
have used it's an illustration it's a
metaphor it's just a way of
communicating or or physically
manifesting an idea that transcends the
physical realm so that's what that is
it's the same thing how we talk about
you know we love somebody with our heart
but we all know that our heart just
pumps blood there's not love actually
located in our heart we know that maybe
you don't know that but we do and
Christians don't think that God is magic
either you know they believe that God is
a first mover the first mover the first
cause who transcends our physical
dimension and who created it and who
sustains it and who animates it and this
belief bears no relation whatsoever to
the one that you pretend that we hold
none you could disagree with the belief
but you can't disagree with the belief
if you don't understand it and so what I
find with you no atheism in modern
America has become very lazy and to be
fair Christianity has become very lazy
to there a lot of lazy Christians who
don't understand their own beliefs and
that's part of the problem here that
there's a lot of biblically illiterate
people in the world including Christians
but atheism is also very lazy may be
lazier now that it used to be and so you
just have a lot of really lazy atheists
running around saying oh yeah magical
sky genie just spending all their energy
shouting at people for holding beliefs
that nobody actually holds here's
another example I think a little bit
more common you have the secular person
who skims through Leviticus or exodus or
rather they skim through a blog written
by someone who has skimmed through one
of those things and then they demand to
know why Christians eat sell shellfish
and why we wear mixed fibers and why we
cut our beards and and they'll say oh
you so you think it's wrong for gays to
marry but what about you look at you you
got you have tattoos look what Leviticus
says about that again they don't they
try to hold us to the standards of the
old law because they don't understand
this extremely basic foundational
doctrine of Christianity that
distinguishes between the old and new
law this is not just like some
Christians do this is basic fundamental
Christianity that if you are a Christian
you must believe again they show how
they have disdain for something that
they do not even slightly understand you
see Christianity is hated in our culture
because our culture doesn't understand
it so it's actually not even true to say
that Christianity is hated people hate
what they perceive Christianity to be
it's certainly possible for a person to
study Christianity understand it
basically and then reject it you can do
that but it's not possible for an
intelligent rational person to study it
understand it and then treat it as
something just ridiculous and and
childish and inane and stupid that you
can't do if you're a smart person
because anyone with that attitude which
is the majority of em American atheist
and even some Christians anyone with
that with that attitude reveals
themselves to be uninformed in
unintelligent this is a belief system
that has been believed and accepted and
embraced by not only you know billions
of people across the world but also some
of the most some of some of the greatest
geniuses in the history of mankind
whether we're talking about Aquinas or
Augustine or da Vinci you know or
Michelangelo Shakespeare I mean go down
the list
some of the the greatest geniuses ever
to exist on planet earth have not only
been Christians but devout Christians no
that doesn't prove that Christianity is
correct all by itself but it does prove
that if you're a serious person this is
something you take seriously you don't
just say to whatever no see you're not
allowed to do that with a belief system
held by Thomas Aquinas
if you're a smart person if you're a
smart person you say wow this is a
towering genius I mean I should look
into what he's saying right I mean I
should at least listen but if you're
ignorant if you're foolish if you're
childish
if you're unintelligent or more so if
you're an intellectual coward that's
when you take when you look at this
belief billions of people hold it
throughout their millions people have
died for this belief some of the
smartest people in the history of the
world I mean our our civilization is
founded on this belief and you have to
be very very frankly stupid to look at
that and just say whatever again I'm not
saying that if you decide you don't
believe that means that you're stupid
I'm saying if you have that attitude of
just I don't even care
I'm not even gonna look at it it's
something that you need to take
seriously and then when you look at the
history of Christianity there's even
more reason to take it seriously
when you look at the fact that
Christianity was born in violent
oppression has endured it relentlessly
ever since its founder was this obscure
carpenter who was brutally executed only
three years into his public ministry and
it's early apostles and evangelists were
these really unimpressive average men
who carried this carpenter's message in
defiance of government authorities and
religious leaders and an empire and they
died for it and its disciples embraced
this new way of life that would only
lead to suffering and poverty and death
there was nothing else promise they
weren't probably promised riches they
weren't promised new land they were
promised anything but suffering poverty
and death and for 300 years
that's all it gave them was
offering poverty and death and yet it
flourished and it conquered and its
triumph and millions and millions of
people saw something in the religion
worth dying for and no that does not
prove that it's true but it does prove
that you should look at it and take it
seriously and say to yourself I want to
understand this thing maybe all of those
people are wrong but there's no way I
can arrive at that conclusion until I
have taken a time to understand it a lot
of people are our culture just are not
willing to do that and so in lieu of
understanding they just say why
understand it when I can hate it and I
just think that's very foolish and then
if you understand it you you avoid some
of the embarrassment that poor Chuck
Todd and the poor lady at NPR have
suffered over the last few days all
right thanks for watching everybody and
hope you have a great day I'll talk to
you next time